Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors here to answer some very important questions.
Here's the question we get. Can I just buy a programmed rife from you and how do you program it?
What do you know what to do?
How has that done? How does that work?
The answer is quite simple. It's yes, that's what we do. I've been doing this for many, many years started working with rife machines back in the
90s
So whatever year it is now, you could do the math. So currently we are programming the true rife f122
That's the latest model of true rife. That is the
model that we used. I think it's the best for multiple reasons. I have a bunch of videos on that.
To me, rife is only as good as the, you know, several factors. It has to have enough power to penetrate your body.
If it has more power than that, that's great, but it's kind of wasted if the bulb is next to you.
You want to have a bulb. You have to use light frequency first of all.
So any of these little handheld machines that you're holding different things and stuff to me, they might have validity,
but in my mind, I'm just giving you my opinion. I don't think it really is going to make a big difference in your health.
So it has to use light frequency. Light is a photon carry it out of wavelength.
And it's using the frequencies going through that light wavelength.
So everything is programmed on a laptop. So we actually provide a laptop with our purchases.
So if you purchase a rife from us, the program will be the current version six at this time of this
making this video. If they ever come up with a new version, you'll get the latest version.
And you get all that comes with it about 25, almost 2500 other programs for just about everything you can possibly think of.
Possibly my specific programming for you. So all the programming is on the laptop.
The machine then connects to the laptop. And when you hit run on the program on the laptop, it sends the program to the machine.
You can close the laptop. That's what we recommend people do.
And put the bulb next to you. That's how you use the machine.
So many times people will put this little machine that you see in blue, the true rf 122.
Put that underneath the bed. Put the laptop at their bed side and put the bulb in bed with it.
Now why are we talking in bed? Because we typically tell members to use it at night while they sleep.
Now you can run any of the other programs that are available. Some of them are three minutes long.
Some of them are three hours long, depending on the program.
You can run those anytime during the day. But when I write a program, I'm typically writing programs for overnight use.
Unless you specify that you want shorter programs. Some people do. Please write two hour programs for cancer.
Please write three hour programs for my autoimmune disease.
However, you want the program written out gladly, accommodate that and do that.
But with patients that are members that have cancer, we have always written overnight programs.
Because I want them to get the rife frequencies while they sleep so they can live during the day.
That's just part of our philosophy. I don't want you tied to a machine or anything like that that you
have to do during the day and then sometimes you're feeling better, you just don't do it.
So at night you have to sleep any how, hey, you might as well be using the therapy while you're sleeping.
I think there's a huge benefit to that. So that's how we program it.
Now it comes in a case. So the true rife machine is in the case. It also comes with a foot bath,
eye on pro wave, that a lot of people use on a daily basis and some people don't use it at all.
It just, it does take time to do. It comes also with the crystal hammer tube, which is an upgrade.
I just think there's benefit to the crystal hammer tube. It could split the frequencies and help
when a frequency, when an organism or something is trying to morph, just try to stay alive.
I think the crystal hammer tube is a nice upgrade.
And also like I said, it comes with the laptop computer, it comes with the grouding bat
that you use. I recommend only when you're doing the eye on pro wave and then it comes with the
computer that's not seen here. So how is it programmed? Okay, that's a question I always get. Well,
to be honest with you, it's really programmed. All the progress that by me and it's based upon I've
been doing this a long time. So I have written programs for just about every health condition that you
could think of. And if somebody has one that I have never written a program for, then I'm doing
research, finding frequencies and writing a program for that specific thing, I just feel like this
is my mission to help people. And if they come to me with something I don't have never helped anybody
with before, then I figured out how to use right frequencies for that. Remember, we're not
promising to cure. This isn't, quote, unquote, a treatment. We're not offering medical advice.
This is frequencies to stimulate your body to do things against a disorder dysfunction
and bring back function to your body. That's the goal of right treatment. So I'm using my experience.
I'm using all my data and my experience along with what has been done by other practitioners.
This is what your home screen will look like on your true right. So when you open up your home screen,
it's going to look just like this. It's hard to read. It's very small. But you see folders on the
left hand side where it starts with autism, sets body function programs, cancer programs,
clear line programs. So there's programs in those folders that it goes down, down below those
little yellow folders. It goes to an alphabetical list of all the programs that you scroll through it.
That literally I think there's 2,400 plus programs now. But we want to get really specific to you.
So if you're going to purchase a right machine from us, we're going to I'm going to program it for you.
So in the store, if you purchase a right machine that says prerequisite, complete this educational
intake form and you'll click on that and it'll bring you to a form. It's not a medical intake
form. It's an educational intake form where you give us how you want me to program your right.
So that's where, like I said before, if you want, hey, you know, I have a son with autism.
Could you put some like you can't sit for more than 15 minutes. Could you put 15-minute programs
together day programs for him? I have a daughter that has, you know, headaches. Could you put
some programs in for her? It's best to specify minutes if you possibly can or hours or whatever.
And maybe I have breast cancer. So I would like an overnight program for my breast cancer. So tell
us all that stuff. So it gives me clues on how to write this program. And then I actually, as I create
that program, I put it as AA your name and it might be, if it's a family program, if there's a
program for your husband and the wife and then the children in that folder, it will be a folder
and it'll have the names of those people. So it's best to specify that as best you can on that form
who you want those for and the minutes and because it just gives me instructions on how to do it
best for you because again, you know, we want the right machine to be usable. You can have the
greatest, you could have a CT scan at home. If you don't use it, it doesn't go any good. So you have to
have tools that you could utilize and that they could be a part of your life and that they could be
a benefit to your health when we're talking about health tools like this. So I want to be as specific
as possible. So I put AA before your name so it comes out alphabetically first. So it'll be the
first folder. When you open your home screen on your right, that's going to be the folder that's going
to be your first folder that you see. One information here, but it's, it's, when you go to the store to
purchase the right, you'll see where you could fill out that form. The more information you give us
on that educational intake form, the better it will be. Now, sometimes people need it reprogram.
Sometimes they need something changed. Like, oh, no, my daughter's headaches are great using the same
example, but she's having some, you know, issues with X, Y and Z. Can you program that? We're here to
do that. There's a cost of that for that. And right now, I think it's $135. It might go up or down.
Time goes on. But we're here to reprogram that and tweak your program, you know, as you want that
tweak. Because again, I want you to be able to use this. So we're here for customer service. We're here
to pray for you too. So when we have our prayer box for you to submit prayers, we mean that. So we
will be here to pray for you in anything you need as well. We have other services available that you
can add on through our courses. Certainly look at those as well. They will give you a plethora of
information that will help you in different ways as well. And know that we'll be praying for you
through your health, journey, through your life. God has a plan in this as He does in all things.
Thanks so much. Bye-bye.